mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
wird das leben nach corona je wieder so
sein wie es einmal war
ich glaube dass wir versuchen werden den
ausgangszustand wieder herzustellen wäre
das überhaupt möglich
jetzt glaube ich dass wir eine zeit auch
der abkühlung entschleunigung geraten
wird es gewinner und verlierer geben
gerade die schwächsten trifft die krise
am stärksten unser gewohnter lebensstil
steht auf dem prüfstand
ganz gleich wieder gott dann werde die
narbe wirklich entsetzlich und da nicht
die menschen
kulturplatz sucht den weitblick
[Musik]
willkommen bei kulturplatz ja es ist zum
heulen der nabu auch das zürcher
schauspielhaus ist außer gefecht während
hier gerade ein stück hätte premiere
feiern sollen das wohl prophetischer
nicht hätte sein können
das weinen von christoph marthaler wir
wollen heute aber nicht jammern sondern
auch tapfer in die zukunft schauen
so
[Musik]
bei allem lockerungs optimismus der
gerade breit bespielt wird wir müssen
uns alle auf eine lange phase fairen
einstige normalität einstellen während
nun also politiker um steuerungs hoheit
bohlen und virologen am erkenntnisgewinn
arbeiten wollen wir heute durch eine
andere brille dem zukunft blicken
worüber debattiert die soziologie welche
prognosen macht sie für die zeit nach
der krise
wann werden wir das wieder erleben
geselligkeit unbeschwertes zusammen sein
dass corona virus setzt viele
fragezeichen was folgt auf die krise
verändern wir unser konsumverhalten
unser zusammenleben unsere mobilität
oder gar unserer politischen strukturen
wir wissen es nicht aber einen blick auf
die zeit nach der krise zu werfen
lohnt sich vorher hatten wir überall
steigerungen steigerungen steigerung
ja und jetzt glaube ich dass wir in eine
zeit auch der abkühlung der
entschleunigung geraten ist laut dass
wir versuchen werden in ausgangszustand
wiederherzustellen
hartmut rosa ist soziologe und
politikwissenschaftler und forscht etwa
zur geschwindigkeit unserer gesellschaft
unter verantwortung des einzelnen
der publizist matthias horx hat ein
zukunftsinstitut gegründet er beobachtet
trends und stellt prognosen
die soziologin katja rost lehrt und
forscht an der universität zürich wo sie
die gleichstellungskommission leitet
sehr oft wird gesagt diese krise sei
auch eine chance
ist das wirklich so und wenn ja eine
chance wofür man muss erst einmal sehen
dass es etwas unbeabsichtigtes und
problematisches ist also problematisch
in medizinischer hinsicht weil es
menschenleben kostet weil es leid über
menschen bringt es ist problematisch und
ökonomischer hinsicht weil viele
menschen jetzt um ihre existenz fürchten
und vielleicht auch wirklich in armut
geraten
insofern gibt es da nichts schönzureden
eine krise wird ja erst dann erst zu
einer straße wenn sie ein change also im
englischen gesprochen dann auslöst also
einen tatsächlichen wandel es ist glaube
ich eine ganz große nachdenkt
möglichkeit für die gesamte gesellschaft
denken wir also nach wie könnte ein
positiver wandel aussehen wird die welt
solidarischer die schere zwischen arm
und reich kleiner
man hört er auf dem spruch vor dem virus
sind alle gleich das stimmt leider so
nicht nämlich gerade die schwächsten
trifft die krise am stärksten home
office können nur die gebildeten
schichten machen der rest ist von
kurzarbeit betroffen von
arbeitslosigkeit oder muss ich eben dem
virus am arbeitsplatz beispielsweise im
verkauf aussetzen insofern
zunächst davon auszugehen dass soziale
ungleichheit in der krise kurzfristig
ansteigen wird
eine chance läge also allenfalls in der
besinnung auf solidarität in einem neuen
mindset wie sieht es zum beispiel mit
der gleichberechtigung der geschlechter
aus pflegeberufe und die sogenannte car
arbeit die viele frauen verrichten
erhalten in der pandemie mehr
anerkennung
applaus ist nett doch werden auch die
gehälter steigen führungspositionen
demnächst gleichberechtigt besetzt ein
aspekt an krisen der gegen die frauen
spricht und zwar über im krisen vertraut
man auf alte status ordnungen die
gewinne wieder an bedeutung
und das bedeutet dass zum beispiel der
stapel männliche führer dass der wieder
stärker verlangt es nach der krise oder
eben in zeiten in denen jobs auch
wachsen und die arbeitslosen schlangen
werden weltweit länger
die wirtschaftlichen daten gewisse
politische reaktionen auf das virus
stimmen nicht unbedingt optimistisch
handel und mobilität bleiben erst einmal
eingeschränkt so einfach werden wir
nicht mehr in die ferne reisen können
manche produktion gerät durch die krise
ins stocken
sie führt zu dem was wir die
lokalisierungen also eine neue mischform
zwischen globalen und lokalen
wir werden natürlich in zukunft viel
mehr produktionen auch die
nahrungsmittelproduktion wieder in den
regionalen und internationalen räumen
oder auch in den kontinentalen räumen
stattfinden lassen
weniger waren verkehr rund um den globus
mehr regionale selbstversorgung ein
vorläufiger gewinner der korona krise
der nationalstaat eine gute entwicklung
unsere grenzen werden wieder stärker
kontrolliert manch einer fürchtet eine
verschiebung zum autoritären staaten
hatten sicherlich ein vorteil in der
akuten krisenbewältigung einfach
gestrickt sind da muss man mit niemandem
abstimmen das ist bei denen standort
zustand ja sie müssen aber auch sehen
dass danach sozusagen bei der
krisenbewältigung in gesellschaftliche
integration ganz ganz wichtig ist dass
gesellschaften wieder funktionieren
können
und hierfür braucht es
mitbestimmungsrechte der staat ist ja
nicht per se er uns gegenüber stehende
vielleicht sogar feindliche instanz
sondern es ist unser instrument zum
politischen handeln die schweiz hat da
sehr lange historische erfahrungen damit
dass sie den staat begreifen als das
instrument in den bürgerinnen und bürger
gemeinsam handeln können und dieses
instrument wird gerade gestärkt
also sobald das uns wieder gelingt das
an die bären die legislativen parlamente
zurückzubinden kann die demokratie als
sieger daraus hervorgehen was wir
derzeit erfahren politik kann etwas
ändern
die regierungen haben verantwortung
getragen an uns liegt es daraus eine
chance zu machen
politikverdrossenheit war gestern
[Musik]
ja da sieht sich nun in den leeren
reihen des frauen mit diesem programm
heft vom märz das in die geschichte
eingehen wird gerade noch hatten sie auf
der bühne gestanden um die generalprobe
von marthalers das weinen zu meistern
bereits im wissen darum dass gleich im
anschluss die vollbremsung kommt
lockdown ausgerechnet bei diesem stück
letzten herbst geschrieben entwickelt es
nun eine geradezu unheimliche aktualität
das weinen spielt in einer apotheke
sie steht für eine kranke welt die
dringend heilung braucht doch die
hoffnung auf ein wirksames medikament
entpuppt sich letztlich als trügerisch
ein typischer smart aller stück ohne
stringente handlung metaphorisch und
mini komisch zugleich
wir erreichen den regisseur in hamburg
das stück das risiko beschafft und
nachhaltig gestört wird
das war neben ihr lag das hand kollegen
erlebt wo sie jung sie sind das
tanztheater seiten hat das große rechnet
hat premier league wigan bei der sonne
sondern dass sie das ja ist völlig 90
die solche traf das schauspielhaus mit
voller wucht ein theater bringt menschen
zusammen
und genau das wurde verboten am tag der
generalprobe am freitag den 13
märz
ein paar wenige eingeweihte haben das
weinen aber gesehen
in der generalprobe 2 art ein bisschen
endzeit und hat das gefühl man erlebt
jetzt etwas sehr außergewöhnliches
außerordentliches wer weiß wann ist dann
wirklich auf die bühne kommt wir saßen
alle etwas auseinander gesetzt
das individuum war in der gruppe aber es
waren wirklich sehr spezieller moment
und extrem spannend natürlich es war ob
sie traurig dass das stück der stunde
wenn jetzt im atlantik gezeigt werden
das stück wo wahrscheinlich am
notwendigsten gezeigt werden konnte
zeigt werden will
sie wüssten warum der hand gar nicht ist
für mich irgendwo im unbewussten könig
das hat als wirklich völlig überrannt
und sehr einig dass ich ja so plakativ
also was man ständig an wissen also
eines mundschutz collect deshalb vor
dass ich das ist ein wirklich plant aber
aber als ich zum glück auf ersichtlich
nicht platt so und das hat sehr viel mit
wo kommst du her und daher ist mich nach
dem harten und kalten stahl und stein
die meisten dieser texte stand und die
tat einem schweizer universalkünstler
der viel schrieb und der christoph
marthaler einst ein buch schenkte das
wild aus dieser text sammlung ist das
theaterstück entstanden
hier droht ein großartiger künstler wohl
nicht kann kann mit sehr gut aber werden
diese stoffe und ganz toll unterhausen
und ich einfach seit der ort ist
irgendwie das gegenteil sie ist der sky
installation er amtiert erotisch und ein
update wo eigentlich ein ort und
verzweiflung und hoffnung so benannt
sind
dass das ein ort ist wo aber sehr viel
indirekt mit seinen texten aus dem store
denn roth hält der welt den spiegel vor
und marthaler tut nun mit rot texten
genau dasselbe
er hofft auf einen heilsamen schock mit
nachhaltiger wirkung nicht nur im
theater sondern in unserer realität
gerichte so einfach dass ihr business
muss neu auf man muss um dann bis 19
passiere wenn man es gleich wieder gab's
dann werde die narbe wirklich
entsetzlich und dann nicht
[Musik]
die alten rezepte und medikamente taugen
nichts mehr
was bleibt ist das beweinen einer welt
die unter geht die große ratlosigkeit
wie kann sie überwunden werden
[Musik]
susanne marie wrage sie haben noch
geprobt für das weinen
inwiefern steht denn für sie jetzt diese
inszenierung mit dieser apotheke für die
realität
naja die apotheke ist natürlich jetzt
wurde zum sinnbild gemacht letzten endes
das war gar nicht unsere absicht denke
ich als wir angefangen haben zu proben
es ist natürlich metaphorisch für die
für die jetzige zeit noch mehr als das
ursprünglich gedacht war und jetzt
schauen wir da in dieser leeren regale
und es standen sie auf der bühne bei der
generalprobe im wissen danach ist
schluss wie frustrierend war das für sie
sehr frustrierend also sehr traurig und
es wahrscheinlich so eine stunde null in
einer gewissen weise wahrscheinlich ist
dass im moment an dem er sich erinnert
wie wo man heute noch weiß wo man war
als september leben war ich denke das
ist genau so ein moment den das hirn
sich merkt und immer verknüpfen wird mit
dem ort wo man wo man war
ich habe jetzt nie die sorge gehabt dass
das stück weg bleibt das wird sicherlich
gespielt werden und schade ist dass es
nicht gespielt werden kann im moment
es wurde ja auch zum stück der stunde in
einer gewissen weise also das war ja
auch nicht so angelegt aber es ist ja
wirklich absurd wie sehr es nun in die
zeit passt plötzlich können sie mit dem
schlagwort krise als chance im moment
etwas anfang längerfristig weiß ich
nicht ob es eine chance ist ich denke im
ersten moment ist es eine chance dass
man
hält was alle gezwungenermaßen tun
müssen und sich gezwungenermaßen mit
sich auseinandersetzen mit ihrer
lebenssituation mit ihrer familie das
modell was man lebt das sicherlich von
vielen leuten in frage gestellt wird
kann ich mir vorstellen weil man
wirklich komplett auf sich
zurückgeworfen wird und eine chance ich
weiß nicht ob eine chance eine ist wenn
sie einem aufgezogen wird das ist so
meine große frage also wenn man ich bin
vielleicht wieder ständig im geiste wenn
mich jemand zwingt so etwas dann mache
ich das gegenteil und insofern ich weiß
nicht ob es eine chance interessanter
gedanke auf jeden fall ganz herzlichen
dank
[Musik]
sie leben in italien hätten noch die
möglichkeit gehabt dorthin zurück zu
reißen was sie nicht getan haben wie
schwierig war diese entscheidung die
viele ja das war schon schwierig wie
alles in dieser zeit aber anstatt nach
mailand zurückzukehren war es einfacher
hier zu bleiben denn die lebensqualität
hier ist gegenwärtig besser man darf aus
dem haus gehen wenn man will auch wenn
empfohlen wird es nicht zu tun
[Musik]
und die idee zu reisen hat mich
abgeschreckt damals schon und auch jetzt
noch
dank des zürcher schauspielhauses kann
ich hier bleiben so lange es nötig ist
ich kann in einer gast wohnung leben nun
sind sie also hier fern der heimat und
fern des verlobten wie isoliert fühlen
sie sich denn mir fehlen alle sehe meine
familie mein verlobter meine freunde und
die kollegen in italien
aber es war die richtige wahl für mich
und alle anderen es ist wichtig reisen
zu vermeiden und distanz zu wahren und
dank des internet kontakt fällt es mir
etwas weniger schwer besser als nichts
halt
[Musik]
ja das perfekte requisit den heute in
unserer serie sieben künstlerinnen und
ein virus geht es um das krisen
hilfsmittel schlechthin um musik einst
in der ecke verstorbene instrumente die
schreien ja geradezu danach endlich mal
wieder berührt zu werden
naja aber während ich zu hause nun hier
und da auf sehr tiefen niveau mal wieder
meinen e bass zupft er wagt sich der
schauspieler andrea zogg an den
akustischen bruder seit fünf wochen nun
übt der schauspieler andrea zogg ein
stück von johann sebastian bach auf dem
bass alltag in freiwilliger quarantäne
[Musik]
andrea zogg ist einer von sieben
künstlerinnen und künstlern die uns
videos schicken und nachdenken über das
leben mit dem virus
diesmal mit nur zwei stimmen neben
andrea zogg opernstar regula mühlemann
20 an der krise ist ja das jeden tag
ich schwöre bis anders und wieder
business machen nicht wirklich bleiben
und die finde es gibt sehr viele frau
gezahlt das gibt sehr viele frohe kunde
arbeitet wieder in gang
wir sind sie überhaupt in gang was gott
was ich nur dass ich so große
unsicherheit womit wir nicht weiß wo das
jetzt hier gott in seinem youtube kanal
tv falls seiner pretty lies dann der zug
gedichte die ihm zugeschickt werden
es kam die sintflut ohne wasser und
keine arme weit und breit
er zeigt filme und musikalisches und
fragt sich was wird geschehen wenn die
krise vorbei ist
ich bin überzeugt dass wir mitten in
eine zeitenwende sind es wird noch
corona wirklich vieles vieles anders
standard weil szenario aber jetzt
entwickle anzeiger positiv sei die
globalisierung wird aber klar dass gibt
das allgemeine grundig bremer produziert
und region ist das was du wachst und es
wirkt alles entschleunigt und der domo
turbo kapitalismus konto kanada dass ich
dir positiv variante die negativ
variante heißt mehr werden überwacht die
große gewinnen es wird dutzend die hunde
die tausende von leser werden stärker es
wird als arbeitslose her gehe es geht
eine installation und es geht kein blick
mehr für wanderer und kann
hallo zusammen ich bin regula mühlemann
opern und konzertsängerin ja so kann ich
sie in quarantäne
regula mühlemann hat uns einen konzert
ausschnitt aus dem letzten jahr
geschickt sie singt eine arie aus
kleopatra von georg friedrich händel und
denkt nach über sich und sich als
sängerin
[Musik]
ich jetzt wirklich ermordet nur statist
verstehen wo am glücklichsten wenn sie
fehler machen wieso ich bin mir die luft
man sich nicht gar nicht dass eine
wirkliche künstlerin wo durch und durch
die phase vor ihrem körper system
[Musik]
und ich muss sagen und ich habe gemerkt
dass das ein schöner könnte sich also
reglement hätte der musik
[Musik]
was mir graut geschnitten sondern singen
mit andere mehr
musik machen
[Musik]
und wie sieht regula mühlemann die
zukunft positive steht zurücklegen und
nicht nur das quartett als versteht die
angst vor dem alter
[Musik]
die hoffnung für zukunft ist groß für
mich ist das so schön zu sehen dass man
den sieg wieder einfach kultur braucht
wie brot das ist für die psychische
wohlbefinden einfach essentiell ist
und nächste woche episode 5 und die
frage was tun in der krise ja das war es
von uns aus dem zürcher schauspielhaus
hier auf sf1 geht es jetzt weiter mit
der ersten staffel kleine lügen ja und
nächste woche da spreche ich mit dem
musiker endo anaconda über seine
abschiedstour von der sich vorerst
verabschieden musste aber eines kann ich
versprechen wir werden den humor nicht
ganz außer acht lassen
mit dem mann aus dem emmental in diesem
sinne
wie tief
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen ihr kultur
tourismus
[Musik]